so if you get married what do you want
that marriage to look like oh um if I
get married I would like I would like to
have a guy that I can try I look at it
similar to my relationship with like my
dad which I don't know if that's is that
weird I don't know I was thinking about
this the other day but like some will
have a problem with how you worded it
but it's up to you it's your word okay
because I think of my dad and same with
my brother like I'll give you an example
I trust my dad so much I hate accounting
my dad makes me do the accounting myself
every month and every month I'm like why
can't we hire an accountant I don't
understand why I do this myself and my
dad's like look it you you have to know
your numbers
my dad's like that too yeah and I'm like
fine and I do it because I trust my dad
because I'm like my dad wouldn't like
steer me insane with uh my brother Adam
it's really similar too
um and that's kind of a relationship
that I'd like to have similar with my
husband where even if like I disagree
with him I it's like you trust his
judgment